now back to CPAC and suburban Washington
conservers conservatives gathered across
the Potomac in Maryland they're not only
listening to some of their ideological
leaders they're getting hands-on
training in activism correspondent Peter
Doocy reports on grassroots training for
the right Republicans know they've got a
mammoth midterm challenge ahead because
2018 is a do-over for Democrats we
thought they were gonna win the White
House in 2016 they're awake they're
ready to come at these midterms and
hopefully take that back the majority so
we have to be just as energized I expect
presidential level turnout in a lot of
states and the president is predicting a
problem for his party so people are
sitting there and they're saying we just
hit that grid for yeah let's not vote
let's go to a movie the Republican Party
we're gonna do great and then they end
up losing so you got to keep up the
enthusiasm so CPAC hosted an activist
boot camp to share strategy as Senate
hopefuls are refining their pitches to
keep Republicans interested Michigan's
John James a veteran and businessman
thinks casting a wide net will help him
unseat senator debbie Stabenow I swore
an oath to support and protect the
Constitution United States against all
enemies foreign and domestic
and that requires firing up our base
without alienating traditional
Republicans and making sure that we hold
Democrats in the state of Michigan
accountable for their misdeeds and
neglect arizona's dr. kelly ward running
to replace Senator Jeff Flake plans to
highlight her status as an outsider we
as Republicans have to give our
electorate candidates that inspire them
to go to the polls and Ohio businessman
like Gibbons hoping to unseat senator
sherrod Brown plans to make his campaign
a tribute to Trump as I live in
Cleveland Ohio
didn't do too well he throw a rock out a
window and Cleveland chants are gonna
hit a Democrat that sound the state does
not feel that way Donald Trump would win
Ohio by a bigger margin he did he took
the last thing so president Trump's
record is the thing that conservative
candidates think will carry them all the
way to Washington and there is not much
talk about the group about things they
wish president Trump could be doing
differently or should be doing
differently to help their chances more
instead these candidates seem content
that what the president has done to date
could be enough
Brett Peter Doocy live at CPAC Peter
thanks